l'arctique cet endroit où l'eurasie
l'amérique du nord et l'asie pacifique
se rend compte qu'on est en train de
devenir un lieu de tension majeure dans
l'équilibré géopolitique mondiale
l'évolution climatique laisse prévoir
que l'océan arctique sera totalement
libre de glace est ouvert la navigation
vers 2040 2050
il est clair qu'au delà de la route
maritime la fonte des glaces ouvre
l'accès à d'énormes possibilités
les européens comme les américains ont
tardé à prendre conscience des défis
économiques et militaires qui pointe
derrière l'enjeu environnemental plus la
glace fond et plus les appétits
grossissement
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 17 juin
demir poutine se dit prêt à poursuivre
le dialogue si washington l'êtes aussi
déclarations du président russe au
lendemain de sa rencontre avec joe biden
à genève un entretien constructif pour
le président américain positif pour son
homologue russe qui évoque même
aujourd'hui une atmosphère amicale
une nouvelle bataille dans une note
adressée hier au patron de la police
gérald darmanin demande 50 opérations de
contrôle et veut renforcer la lutte
contre les rodéos urbains dans les
quartiers concernés alors qu'ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux notamment en ile
de france et que leur issue est parfois
tragiques
il veut la saisie systématique des deux
roues et quads le clip so that pourrait
bien s'inviter à nouveau dans le débat
alors que son utilisation est autorisée
jusqu'en décembre 2022 en europe le
célèbre herbicide pourrait bien
bénéficier d'une nouvelle homologation
un rapport d'expertisé ne conclut pas la
cancérogénicité du produit deux agences
européennes doivent maintenant examiner
à leur tour le dossier pour exprimer
leurs opinions
[Musique]
venir poutine et joe biden sont donc
rentrés dans leurs pays respectifs
quelles réactions donc au lendemain de
cette rencontre historique pour plus de
précisions direction tout de suite
genève où nous retrouvons notre envoyé
spécial antoine claireaux bonsoir
antoine de retour donc à moscou vladimir
poutine est revenu aujourd'hui assez
longuement sur cette rencontre
oui tout à fait stéphanie à l'issue au
lendemain de cette de ce sommet à genève
l'a dit mi-août in a affiché sa
satisfaction
principalement sur le contenu de ces de
ce sommet le contenu de ces discussions
avec son homologue américain
il est en plus sa participation la
qualité des échanges jouer tout à fait
et plus particulièrement la qualité des
échanges qu'il a eus avec joe biden
vadimir poutine a même paris quelques
paru quelque peu surpris de l'état de
forme du président américain a écouté
aubras capturée aux brosses ce plaisir
de la catonnerie show été lynché l'image
du président maiden créés par nos médias
et même les médias américains n'a rien à
voir avec la réalité
il a accompli un long voyage il est
arrivé de l'autre côté de l'océan ce
qu'il ya le décalage horaire ce qu'on
appelle le jet lag
oui sauf ping spi au kiosque aux
délateurs
moi même quand je voyage en avion cela
me des boussoles et lui il a l'air en
forme nous avait parlé en tête à tête
pendant deux heures peut-être même un
peu plus je serai tout à fait dans le
bon noste au matériel n'ouvrit matt
rimer avec l'aide de temps en temps il
consultait ses papiers mais nous le
faisons tous l'image qui est créée peut
même nous est concentré mais il ne faut
pas by donne est un professionnel et il
faut être très attentif en travaillant
avec pour éviter de manquer quelque
chose
les slims raboter vladimir poutine est
revenu aujourd'hui sur les promesses de
progrès entrevus lors de ce sommet
d'hier en particulier dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité un domaine dans lequel
la russie et bien souvent pointé du
doigt à tort selon le président russe
écouter
ça fait combien d'années que nous leur
proposons de lancer un dialogue à ce
sujet il ne cesse de refuser et nous
reproche absolument tout comme je lé dit
lors de la conférence de presse
aujourd'hui le nombre de cyber attaques
diverses en provenance des états unis
est le plus élevé du monde
nous ne sommes même pas parmi les cinq
premiers pays dans ce domaine
mais tout comme eux nous devons suivre
attentivement ce qu'il se passe c'est
extrêmement important pour comme pour
noah
au lieu de se friter comme on dit se
disputer et chercher des responsables et
serait-il pas mieux d'unir nos efforts
pour lutter contre la cybercriminalité
est ce que tu ne nous en avons discuté
et je dois admettre qu'il est dans le
coup dans tous les domaines j'espère que
la situation qu'on a connu au cours des
années précédentes ne se répétera pas
une pour le laissera travailler
tranquillement
mimoun la cacp et de 2 chez good autres
avec le retour des ambassadeurs à leur
poste mais aussi le retour d'un dialogue
sur des sujets clés tels que la
cybersécurité on vient entendre mais
aussi la stabilité stratégique et bien
ce sommet marque en quelque sorte une
nouvelle étape dans les relations entre
la russie et les etats unis en attendant
genève a retrouvé son calme habituel
après ces derniers jours de frénésie
mais aussi de restriction pour les
habitants de tout de toute
l'agglomération genevois cette rencontre
a été donc une séquence importante très
intense également pour la suisse et son
président guy parmelin et avec
l'organisation réussie de ce sommet bien
le pays renoue avec sa tradition de
médiation et de diplomatie au plus haut
niveau international
genève est de son côté joe banner lui
aussi de retour au pays est la maison
blanche précisément après cette première
tournée en tant que président des états
unis
pour plus de précisions retrouve notre
reporter thomas bonnin en direct de
washington
un bon soir plutôt bonjour thomas joe
biden qui a donc achevé son premier
voyage à l'étranger en tant que
président américain quel bilan tires tu
en outre atlantique notamment dans les
médias et bien stéphanie vous avez une
partie de la presse qui est vous savez
plutôt clémente avec joe biden et qui a
apporté un regard bienveillant sur le
périple du président américain en europe
en vantant le retour d'une véritable
diplomatie en mettant en avant également
l'expérience de joe biden sur la scène
internationale puisque vous savez il a
été vice président des états unis
il a beaucoup voyagé à l'époque dans le
cadre de cette fonction alors les débats
ici portent sur le vainqueur de ce duel
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
comme s'il s'agissait d'un combat de
boxe ou d'un match de football
alors vous avez une partie des médias
qui explique que joe biden a gagné on
met en avant notamment la posture la
gestuelle le body language comme on dit
ici des deux présidentes avec un peu
mort est un peu de mauvaise foi parfois
il faut bien le dire notamment lorsque
je pense à un journaliste de cnn qui a
précédé captures d'écran sur son compte
twitter avec notamment la poignée de
mains de vladimir poutine et de joe
biden en expliquant que vladimir poutine
avait détourné le regard ou encore une
autre photo pour expliquer que
l'ambiance était particulièrement
présente entre les deux hommes alors
qu'en réalité lorsqu'on regarde l
intégralité des images ce n'est pas
vraiment l'analyse qu'on pouvait faire
de la situation que vous avez d'autres
médias qui eux pour leur part expliquent
que vladimir poutine sort renforcée de
cette rencontre avec le président
américain et on sent dans leurs oeufs
dans leurs articles qu'ils le regrettent
en quelques sortes sont souvent des
médias plutôt du côté des républicains
en tout cas beaucoup reviennent aussi
sur la conférence de presse de joe biden
on sait que les équipes de la maison
blanche avait pris le soin de ne pas
faire une conférence de presse conjointe
entre les deux présidents pour éviter
les critiques qui avaient été adressées
à l'époque contre donald trump en 2018
lors de sa rencontre avec vladimir
poutine
helsinki alors le résultat c'est une
conférence de presse qui a était
millimétré très préparé peut-être un peu
trop d'ailleurs pour joe biden puisque
le sentiment qu'on aille dans les
analyses qui ressorte on a d'un côté
vladimir poutine qui a répondu aux
questions des journalistes pendant une
heure des journalistes russes mais aussi
des journalistes étrangers dont des
journalistes américains et puis de
l'autre côté vous avez joe biden qui a
d'abord lu un texte sur son téléphone
teurs pendant une dizaine de minutes
avant de répondre à cette question qui
avait été préalablement choisis des
questions qui étaient de la part de
journalistes accrédités auprès de la
maison blanche est donc uniquement des
journalistes américains d'ailleurs au
moment où joe biden a quitté la
conférence de presse où il a remis sa
veste remis ses lunettes de soleil avait
encore des questions qui fusaient de la
part des journalistes présents preuve
qu'il y avait peut-être un goût de trop
peu et ça a d'ailleurs donné lieu à une
passe d'armes entre joe biden est une
journaliste de cnn l'incident était en
train de faire un peu polémique sur les
réseaux sociaux si bien que quelques
instants plus tard au moment où il est
parti de genève
joe biden a tenu à rencontrer à nouveau
les journalistes qui étaient présents
sur le tarmac pour dans un premier temps
présenté ses excuses pour la journaliste
concerné puis pour répondre encore à
quelques questions preuve qu'il y avait
véritablement un goût de trop peu lors
de la conférence de presse et là encore
quelques petits accrochages on va dire
entre joe biden et un journaliste
écouter cet échange
quelles preuves concrètes avez-vous
depuis trois heures ou plus qui vous
laissent penser que les choses ont bougé
pour être un bon journaliste il faut
être négatif il faut avoir une vision
négative de la vie c'est comme ça que je
vois les choses c'est cette façon que
vous avez tous vous ne posez jamais de
questions positive pourquoi parce que
nous avons un accord nous verrons bien
nous avons un accord pour travailler sur
un accord majeur de contrôle des armes
j'ai commencé à travailler sur des
accords de contrôle des heures pendant
la guerre froide
si on peut le faire pendant la guerre
froide pourquoi pas maintenant nous
verrons bien
nous verrons si cela se produit ou non
reto mâcon et hind et des réactions
politiques
cette fois ce que la prestation de joe
biden a convaincu bien si vous écoutez
les démocrates ils vous diront oui ils
sont évidemment dithyrambique sur joe
biden le président démocrate ils
reprennent en réalité la rhétorique de
la maison blanche depuis le début de ce
voyage en europe à le savoir
l'amérique est de retour les alliances
entre les etats-unis et les pays
occidentaux n'ont jamais été aussi
fortes voilà pour la teneur des analyses
qui sont faites par les démocrates mais
de l'autre côté évidemment beaucoup de
critiques de la part des républicains
qui globalement on reproche à joe biden
son manque de fermeté même sa passivité
parfois face à vladimir poutine alors
parmi les critiques parmi les
personnalités qui ont émis ces critiques
on retrouve des anciens membres de
l'équipe donald trump par exemple mike
pompéo qui a été chef de la diplomatie
cependant le mandat de donald trump ou
encore nikki haley qui elle était
représentante des états unis à l'onu et
même l'ancien président donald trump al
donné une interview hier soir à la
chaîne de télévision fox news où il a
décrypté lui aussi le voyage de joe
biden en europe il ya évidemment adressé
beaucoup de critiques à son successeur
notamment sur la gestion du cas du
projet nord stream 2 et en gros donald
trump a expliqué que s'il avait eu la
même posture que celle qui a été adoptée
par joe biden hier et bien les médias
qui aujourd'hui en ce sens joe biden
aurait été très critique contre donald
trump alors la maison blanche a répondu
il ya quelques instants à un certain
nombre de critiques par le biais d'un
conseiller de joe biden en expliquant
que le président américain avait
challenge
la dîmière poutine sur un certain nombre
de sujets mais vous l'aurez compris on
retrouve en réalité le clivage assez
classique ici aux etats-unis entre les
démocrates et les républicains il faut
dire que pour les électeurs américains
la question internationale n'est pas
primordiale une à part s'il ya un
véritable faux pas de la part de leur
président mais joe biden va devoir très
vite se tourner vers les questions
intérieures de son pays a beaucoup de
dossiers compliqués qu'ils attendent
je pense notamment à la gestion de la
frontière sud des états unis avec le
mexique et preuve que le sujet est
particulièrement politique et qui crée
des crispations et bien donald trump
encore lui a annoncé qu'il allait se
rendre sur place dans les prochains
jours oui merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington et pour revenir sur cette
première tournée européenne du président
américain
nous sommes en direct avec françois
durpaire historien spécialiste des états
unis bonsoir françois merci d'être avec
nous en tant que vient de nous le dire
c'était certainement un voyage davantage
scrutées par les observateurs par les
adversaires politiques et les alliés
politiques de joe biden peut-être un peu
moins par les américains eux mêmes il
n'empêche que retenez-vous de ce ses
premiers pas si j'ose dire en tant que
président américain joe biden à
l'international plutôt une réussite
selon vous alors comme comme stéphanie
va transporter là l'a dit avec beaucoup
de justesse c'est pas un match de foot
donc ça veut dire que la différence est
qu'un match de foot on connaît ou khouya
vainqueurs où il ya au moins un match
nul mais on le sait au bout de 90
minutes
et là on ne sait pas là il va falloir
attendre les historiens donc il va
falloir attendre plusieurs années avant
de savoir qu'est-ce que ça véritablement
a produit qu'est ce que ça a produit
dans la relation entre les etats-unis et
l'europe
qu'est ce que ça a produit dans la
relation entre les etats-unis et la
russie
il ya que l'avenir qui pourra nous le
dire alors vous avez dire on aurait
mieux fait de pas vous invitez mais
c'est quand même important de le
préciser
il ya quand même des indices il ya quand
même des indices au moins par exemple
sur la relation entre poutine et balden
si ça s'était mal passé on le saurait
déjà
d'abord parce que il ya une photo d'ap
et qui est sorti on pouvait les deux
hommes riant ensemble se tapant même sur
les puisse cette photo elle n'est pas
anodine si elle sort si elle a été prise
c'est un message très clair que quelque
chose s'est produit le champ lexical
vous avez vu que vladimir poutine a
qualifié jo baydan de professionnels il
a même un peu taclé les médias
américains en dix ans avoue le fait
passer pour un membre ou quelqu'un d'un
peu fragile et un peu âgées moi je les
trouvais très très en forme
et puis il avait même dit avant sa date
pas ça date pas de la rencontre qu'il
avait dit sur nbc il ya quelques il ya
quelques jours que donna que donald
trump lui était impulsif
alors évidemment les républicains
apprécieront mais ça veut dire que du
côté bas demi à poté dans se dit que
finalement mieux vaut peut-être un
président démocrate
avec un sénat légèrement démocrate et
une chambre des représentants démocrates
qui sont un peu plus amène vis-à-vis de
la russie qui est un président de notre
homme qui paraissait vouloir engager une
réconciliation forte une relation
personnelle entre les deux hommes qui
semblait bonne et puis finalement avec
des sénateurs républicains et une
chambre des représentants républicaine
extrêmement dur contre contrôle la
russie
et puis il ya aussi des annonces alors
c'est pas les 99 dossiers de dissensions
qui ont été réglés évidemment mais il ya
quelques annonces retour des
ambassadeurs le fait de travailler sur
la cybersécurité le fait de travailler
aussi sur la réglementation des
armements nucléaires
ce sont des annonces importantes qui
m'ont
ce que quelque chose s'est produit dans
la relation entre la russie et les
etats-unis et le président américain il
ya intérêt parce que finalement que veut
joe biden là il veut simplement que ne
se produise pas eu d'alliance très forte
entre la russie et la chine
parce qu'il ne veut pas que la guerre
froide d'hier avec la russie ne un
handicap en quelque sorte sa guerre
froide a mené d'aujourd'hui et de demain
contre la chine
effectivement c'est ça la clé françois
durpaire la chine qui est d'une certaine
manière pas l'ennemi commun mais en tout
cas le vrai danger vient de là et il ya
eu cette prise réelle de conscience
si si vous regardez stéphanie ce qui a
été dit au sommet de l'otan se met de
temps qu'ils auraient à l'origine
j'allais dire de la création de l'otan
c'était la guerre froide et c'est l
opposition à la russie soviétique là
c'est vraiment la chine qui est visé
c'est dans le texte de la conférence
c'est le défi structurel
la chine est très clairement joe biden
il était venu en europe pour deux
raisons la première raison c'était de
dire on a cette taxe de 15% sur les
entreprises mondialisées et ça c'est
important pour moi parce que je fais de
la diplomatie pour les classes moyennes
américaines
c'est un petit peu l'héritage de d'un
treuil pas de montrer une sorte de
patriotisme diplomatique
et puis le deuxième point c'était de
créer un front commun européen américain
contre la chine qui puisse fonctionner
dans les instances internationales on
pense bientôt g20 on pense à l'om c est
donc c'était l'objectif maintenant est
ce que ça a produit quelque chose ou on
ne sait pas véritablement encore on a
bien vu que joe biden on regarde
fortement du côté allemand
pour l'instant le partenaire européen
parce que
on parle beaucoup de multilatéralisme la
vérité c'est qu'il ya à la fois
multilatérale isme que joe biden va
discuter avec le conseil européen avec
la commission européenne
mais c'est aussi un multi bilatéralisme
l'europe et ça c'est le désavantage
structurelles et institutionnelles de
l'europe c'est toujours des états
désunis d'europe face aux états unis
d'amérique et puis il ya aussi un des
ventes
un des avantages européen sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au niveau de la
pandémie mondiale
les etats-unis sont déjà dans le monde
d'après et l'europe est encore un peu
entre deux eaux vous avez vu pour la
france aujourd'hui on enlève les masques
les américains c'est déjà il y à il ya
plusieurs jours relance économique très
forte
et puis c'est la première puissance
mondiale l'europe n'est pour l'instant
qu'une somme d'économies donc ça veut
dire que bien sûr c'est pas un
multilatéralisme qui se remet en place
mais diriger l'idée par les états unis
est dans le viseur c'est pas
principalement la russie dans le viseur
c'est principalement la chine les
partisans de de joe biden ont salué le
retour d'une vraie diplomatie est ce que
c'est c'est véritablement le cas
aujourd'hui quand on voit cette première
prestation de dob joe biden à
l'international oui il ya deux mots qui
ont qui ont été les mots un peu répété
par la maison blanche pour que ça
finisse par rentrer à l'intérieur des
des médias et on n'est pas obligé de les
reprendre à notre compte mais c'est
stabilité et prévisibilité
ça a été repris aussi par un certain
nombre de dirigeants européens
ça a été aussi leurs prix par vladimir
poutine qui a dit il y a quelqu'un de
professionnel
le précédent était impulsif là on a
quelqu'un de deux stars et les
professionnels alors si la diplomatie ça
veut dire que on a en face de nous
quelqu'un qui va essayer de préparer en
amont
on a vu par exemple la rencontre entre
le premier ministre britannique et le
président américain quelques heures
avant leur rencontre pour aplanir un peu
les difficultés
et essayez aussi de créer une alliance
sur la confiance 6 et essayait bien de
de tenir un peu la parole au moins sur
quelques jours on se rappelle de donald
trump qui repartaient des conférences
internationales avec d'un côté la maison
blanche qui faisait qui avait eu un
discours
et puis de l'autre côté le président
américain qui twittait complètement
autre chose
là ce n'est plus le cas là c'est en
quelque sorte quelque chose d une
diplomatie plus discrète alors plus
discrète mais néanmoins extrêmement
intense un parce que vous avez vu que
cette tournée européenne
c'est le temps c'est le g7 finances et
le g7
c'est le conseil européen la commission
européenne ce et voir tous les chefs
d'état européens qui compte c'est la
lumière coûtait donc on a une sorte de
comme si on avait eu une fringale de
diplomatie pendant quatre ans avec donne
un train que joe maiden tente de
rattraper et finalement l'importance de
la russie on la voit bien en aux etats
unis puisque c'était ça qui était
attendu pas seulement par les
républicains mais par l'ensemble des
américains vis-à-vis des américains ils
ont connu la guerre froide pour les plus
anciens et donc évidemment ils vont être
plus sensible aux chocs des images et à
ce qui s'est produit avec la divers
poutine que ces multi rencontre avec les
chefs d'état et chefs de gouvernement
européens
finalement tous les américains ont dans
la tête un peu la phrase de keith singer
vous rappelez de 1970 sous il disait
l'europe c'est quel numéro de téléphone
l'europe donc les beaucoup d'américains
ne s'y retrouvent pas tellement dans la
politique européenne en revanche ils
comprennent bien qu'il ya la russie et
que c'est une victoire pour la demie un
produit rien que l'organisation d'un
sommet d'ailleurs c'est ce que les
républicains ont reproché à joe biden
d'avoir offert ce sommet à aplanir
poutine
rien que la
rencontre est une est une réussite alors
après pour ce qu'elle a produit sur le
long terme il faudra évidemment attendre
je vous ai dit dans des années
d'historiens nous dira on aura quand
même voir dans les semaines qui viennent
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le
dossier iranien qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur le dossier syrien
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le
dossier chinois qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur le dossier des sanctions
américaines contre la russie tous ces
dossiers vont permettre de voir si
effectivement des lignes ont bougé et si
quelque chose est en train de se
produire dans la relation entre la
russie et les etats-unis qui
convenons-en et vladimir poutine et joe
biden était d'accord sur ce point est au
plus bas
d'ailleurs la réussite du sommet elle
liée à une chose je terminerai par là
c'est que pendant toute la semaine qui a
précédé le sommet on a fait redescendre
au niveau d'attentes en disant oh la la
n'attendez pas grand chose de ce sommet
on était quasiment sûr de pouvoir dire
ben finalement ça s'est pas mal passé
merci beaucoup en tout cas françois
durpaire historien spécialiste des états
unis pour cette analyse complète merci à
vous et le g7 a dansé ce week-end un
accord sans précédent sur une
harmonisation du taux d'imposition des
grandes entreprises à l'échelle mondiale
il a été fixé au moins 15 % ce taux est
censé permettre une meilleure
répartition des recettes fiscales entre
les pays mais certaines entreprises
pourraient y échapper comme amazon
les explications de mona amont dès lors
c'est une petite révolution dans la
fiscalité mondiale les pays du g7 ont
annoncé avoir trouvé un accord sur la
création d'un plancher mondial de 15%
pour l'impôt sur les sociétés une
réforme qui vise les multinationales qui
génère des milliards et qui payent plus
d'impôts comparé à leur chiffre
d'affaires mais ce n'est pas tout les
membres du g7 se sont accordés sur une
autre réforme qui ne doit s'appliquer
qu'aux grands groupes dont la marge
bénéficiaire dépasse les 10% ce qui
signifie qu'une partie des profits des
multinationales sera taxé dans les pays
où elles exercent une activité même sans
leur présence physique
cette mesure vise notamment les
multinationales qui ont choisi
d'installer leur siège social européen
ou lui
ce hambourg afin de bénéficier d'un taux
d'imposition très avantageux c'est le
cas de la filiale européenne d'amazon
qui a élu domicile au luxembourg en 2020
le géant de la vente en ligne a réalisé
320 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et pourtant ce champion de
l'optimisation fiscale pourrait bien
échapper à ces nouvelles mesures
grâce à la règle des 10 % de marge
bénéficiaire proposé par le g7
amazon passerait entre les mailles du
filet car sa marge tourne autour de 6,3
pour cent malgré des profits de
centaines de milliards par an le géant
du e-commerce a en effet une
particularité qui pourrait être à son
avantage
la politique tarifaire d'amazon
agressive pour gagner des parts de
marché son modèle économique plus proche
de la grande distribution que de
l'économie numérique fait qu amazon à
une marge bénéficiaire plus faibles
amazon gère son activité de ventes au
détail en ligne avec des marges
bénéficiaires très faible en partie
parce qu'elle réinvestit massivement et
en partie pour gagner des parts de
marché mais bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie ne veut pas en rester là
la solution tient en une seule chose la
segmentation des activités d'amazon
je souhaite que nous segmentation les
activités d'amazon pour tout ce qui est
très profitable soit bien l'objet de
cette taxation digital et ceux qui à
linverse est moins profitable ne fassent
pas l'objet de la taxation digital
finalement amazon qui brassent des
milliards et échappent aux impôts serait
certes soumis au nouvel impôt mondial
sur les sociétés d'au moins 15% comme
toutes les autres multinationales
en revanche la règle spécialement conçu
pour les géants du net qui contournent
les règles fiscales ne pourrait pas lui
être appliqué du moins pour le moment
l'europe c'est que ces mesures
pourraient rapporter gros à l'échelle
européenne un taux minimum de 15 pour
cent rapporterait 48 milliards d'euros
par an mais la messe n'est cependant pas
encore dite des nouvelles discussions
sont prévues à ce sujet lors du g20
cet été reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des
rodéo sauvage de plus en plus nombreux
en ile-de-france notamment gérald
darmanin veut les éradiquer de ministre
de l'intérieur demande notamment de
saisir systématiquement les deux roues
et quads et puis nous parlerons du
glyphosate un rapport émis par quatre
états membres de l'union européenne dont
la france va dans le sens d'un
renouvellement de l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché de l'herbicide
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour l'étudier
dernière fois que la france était en
2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui c'est tous les fromages tous
les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
enfin les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et au cinéma
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage à
très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
23h français à souhait les bienvenus en
direct sur rt feront si vous nous
rejoignez les adeptes du rodéo urbain
appelé aussi rodéos sauvages ne
resteront plus impunis c'est le message
du ministre de l'intérieur dans une
gérald darmanin a demandé au directeur
général de la police nationale un
certain nombre d'actions contre cette
activité de plus en plus pratiqué des
acrobaties bruyante et dangereuse qui
tue chaque année est les détails en
images
[Musique]
oh
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
bruno bartocetti secrétaire au dessus
des épées police fo bonsoir bruno
bartocetti merci d'être avec nous gérald
darmanin qui demande donc aux policiers
un 50 ans précisément sais pas trop
pourquoi 50 opérations de contrôle et de
la saisie systématique des deux roues
dans les quartiers les plus touchés par
par ces rodéos urbains votre réaction de
policiers ce soir au soir dieu vous
savez pour pour travailler il faut avoir
un certain confort j'ai envie de dire
juridique car vraiment pour pour stopper
ces délinquants c'est de pouvoir les
interpeller en flagrant délit or le
problème c'est que nous avons des nôtres
bien précises là-dessus où on nous
demande de ne pas dans notre jargon de
policiers chasser les personnes qui se
mettent dans une position d'un refus
d'obtempérer
donc c'est là la grande difficulté de
travailler c'est si on doit travailler
de manière à dire dissuasive ou
d'interpeller après l'effraction il va
falloir qu'on soit aussi armé sur un
plan juridique un sachant que des
magistrats bien sûr où un bide de
sanctionner comme nous mais il faut s'en
donner bien sûr les moyens et pas
seulement en renforçant et en plus il
faut en avoir les moyens par 1% les
services de police autour de s'éroder ou
alors pire que cela
cette même note a2 du service de la
commissaire de police de sarcelles
demande à ses effectifs justement de ne
pas entamer de course poursuite
ça veut dire qu'en gros vous êtes un
petit peu impuissant c'est ce que
venez nous expliquer c'est bien sûr
incompréhensif dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens pour nous on a compris qu'il
fallait qu'on travaille mais dès qu'il y
avait on va dire une difficulté bien la
situation sont rentrés se retourner
contre nous donc comprenez bien que nous
aussi nous allons pas nous mettre en
insécurité juridique
je vous prends un exemple seront refus
d'obtempérer il ya quelques temps vous
avez et ça arrive régulièrement
vous avez la personne qui a refusé
d'obtempérer elle a été pourchassé par
les policiers cette personne c'est s'est
blessé mortellement et bien une enquêtes
igpn est en cours autour des policiers
alors nous notre volonté c'est de ne pas
bien sûr d'arriver à un désastre mais en
revanche ce qu'on nous donne les moyens
en effectif pour pouvoir interpeller en
flagrant délit ces personnes là et là la
partie devient très très compliqué alors
les français en tout cas semble être de
votre côté puisque pour 78% d'entre eux
on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans le sujet
un sondage csa pour senio annick 78%
d'entre eux sont favorables à cette
course poursuite
quelle est votre lecture de ce sondage
les français sont à bout
ils comprennent qu'il peut être qu'il ne
faut pas qu un sentiment d'impunité
existe oui on comprend ces sondages on
comprend la population de sauver la
population une soutiennent parce qu'elle
sait où se trouvent les dires les
délinquants c'est pas dans les rangs de
la police et lorsque nous en examen
parce que nous avons fait une chasse
autour de délinquants de la route
voilà on sait aussi très bien où on en
est vous savez je crois que il faut
aller un petit peu plus loin aussi c'est
lorsque nous interpellons le l'auteur
lorsque nous retrouvons en tout cas le
la moto et le quad qui a servi à ce
genre de rodéo c'est au delà de la
saisie un bien sûr ne pas le restituer à
son propriétaire en tout cas il doit
être responsable le propriétaire de ce
rodéo parce que c'est pas forcément lui
qui est sur la moto et c'est là où vous
deviez où ça devient compliqué sur un
plan juridique
et lorsque vous avez des quads ou des
motos qui atteignent 5 6 7 8 10 mille
euros peut-être aussi se poser la
question comment quelqu'un qui touchent
le rsa aps puisse se se payer des motos
à un tel prix voyez il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin à partir du moment où
on a travaillé ce justement autour de
autour de ces rodéos
il faut aller plus loin pour rebâtir
vraiment freiné freiner ce genre de
d'activité et se montrer très durs à
l'endroit des propriétaires de ces quads
parce qu il pour autant qu'au rond qu'il
n'était pas sur la moto en effet si on
ne les interpellés après le délit alors
en tout cas depuis le début de l'année
597 engins ont été saisis 459 personnes
interpellées dans les zones relevant de
la compétence de la police nationale on
a une idée de ce que sont devenus et les
motos et les gens interpellés ils ont
été punis sanctionné alors j'ai pas j'ai
pas vraiment un chiffre précis sur les
sur les sanctions au moins mon sens elle
ne doit pas être très très très hot au
niveau des individus concernant
concernant les motos ou concernant les
quads
si ces dernières ont de la valeur elles
vont être retenues bien sûr par là par
la justice si elles n'ont pas de valeur
ou si elles sont signalées volées elles
sont restitués dans le cas où elles
n'ont pas de valeur et bien sûr si elles
sont signalées volées ce à partir à la
casse ou en tout cas elles seront
restituées aux propriétaires qui a
signalé le vol de sa moto
donc tous j'ai pas de chiffres vraiment
bien précis mais c'est très complexe
pour pour travailler alors on salue
quand même bien sûr la volonté du
ministre l'intérieur mais il faut qu'on
soir mais juridiquement j'insiste bien
là dessus parce que vous savez des
sanctions ne sont pas très très lourde
pour ses ces personnes qui font du rodéo
et qui met pourtant dans paris un péril
la vie de nos concitoyens on a eu un
drame il ya quelques temps où un enfant
de dix ans a perdu la vie à cause
justement de ces inconscients qui font
qu'ils font de la moto d'une manière
manière complètement absurde et
désordonnée merci beaucoup bruno
bartocetti d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl france merci
adoptée début juin au palais bourbon le
projet de loi relatif à la prévention
d'actes de terrorisme et aux
renseignements est actuellement examiné
au sénat le texte pérennise des mesures
d'exception prises après des attaques de
2015 et renforce les moyens légaux
donnée au renseignement ont pris d'une
restriction de liberté individuelle
yamar aussi sans surprise
et contrairement à ce qui avait été
promis à l'époque l'état d'urgence de
2015 ouart a bien fini par s'immiscer
durablement dans le droit commun le
présent projet de loi vise à pérenniser
et à compléter les instruments de
prévention de la commission d'actes de
terrorisme dont le législateur a doté
l'autorité administrative à l'issue de
l'état d'urgence est alors que le niveau
de la menace demeure toujours très élevé
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
au moins c'est assumer on peut ainsi
noter dans ce projet de loi dit relatifs
à la prévention d'actes de terrorisme et
renseignements la perpétuation des mika
ou mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance un
système d'assignation à résidence pour
les personnes suspectées de sympathie de
terroristes ou encore les visites
domiciliaires le nouveau nom des
perquisitions administratives qui sont
désormais soumises à l'accord de
l'autorité judiciaire
la nouvelle loi pérennise également la
possibilité d'instaurer des périmètres
de sécurité en cas d'événement à risque
où le pouvoir administratif de fermer
des lieux de culte des mesures qui n'ont
guère satisfait les observateurs du
respect des droits humains
ce texte vise à pérenniser et même à
renforcer les mesures antiterroristes
exceptionnelles dans nous demandons
l'abrogation depuis plusieurs années car
comme nous l'avons démontré à de
multiples reprises dans nos enquêtes
elle porte atteinte au droit à un procès
équitable au droit à la vie privée et
familiale ou encore au droit au travail
mais si vous avez bien retenu le nom de
cette loi vous avez compris qu'elle
comporte un autre volet relatif aux
renseignements cette fois avec le
renforcement des boîtes noires des
algorithmes de traitement automatisé des
données de communication électronique de
l'ensemble de la population transitant
sur les réseaux des opérateurs de
télécoms et des fournisseurs d'accès à
internet en clair
une écoute généralisée dont l'objectif
est de détecter les germes d'éventuelles
menaces terroristes
selon l'étude d'impact de la nouvelle
loi ces algorithmes aurait généré 1739
alerte pour l'année 2020
le texte pérennise ces boîtes noires
tout en incluant désormais les url c'est
à dire les adresses des sites que nous
consultons toutes ces données de
connexion seront de plus partagés entre
services en fonction de leurs intérêts
et conserver des années durant notamment
à des fins de recherche et développement
notamment en intelligence artificielle
un futur de la surveillance française
qui là encore n'a pas fait que des
enthousiastes
les mesures de surveillance sont
disproportionnées et autorise le
placement sur surveillance de larges
portions de la population française sur
la base de motifs très large sans même
qu'un juge ait donné son accord
or aucune disposition dans le projet de
loi actuel le relatif à la prévention
d'actes de terrorisme et au
renseignement n'est prévu pour résoudre
ces problèmes
au contraire les mesures présentées
pourrait aggraver ces atteintes
le projet de loi semble pourtant avoir
fédéré les élus puisqu'il a été adoptée
à l'assemblée nationale par une très
large majorité de députés y compris
socialistes et ce malgré la procédure
accélérée malgré les délais entre la
présentation du texte en conseil des
ministres et le vote des députés à peine
plus d'un mois très court au regard de
l'importance et de la complexité du
sujet je rappelle que l'étude d'impact à
elle seule fait plus de 250 pages et que
le conseil d'état tout comme la cnil se
sont prononcés sur le texte en émettant
parfois certaines réserves le vote du
sénat est prévu lui dans moins de deux
semaines
et là non plus l'issue ne fait guère de
doute renforçant encore un peu plus les
prérogatives sécuritaire de l'état
son autorisation touche à sa fin mais le
glyphosate pour être encore avoir de
beaux jours devant lui les autorités
nationales des pays rassemblés dans le
groupe d'évaluation sur le mifo that ont
remis leur rapport aux autorités
européennes compétentes
un texte qui ne conclut pas un caractère
cancérogène du produit estelle farges
non cancérogènes c'est ce que conclut la
gg le groupe de pays chargés de la
réévaluation du glyphosate la gg a remis
son premier rapport aux autorités
européennes le 15 juin dernier les
quatre états non identifié aucune
propriétés cancérogènes ray pro toxiques
ou encore mutagènes qui pourrait
justifier l'interdiction du glyphosate
là j'ai conclu que le glyphosate
répondent aux critères d'approbation
pour la santé humaine tel que défini
dans le règlement cee numéro 1107 2009
et ses amendements pour l'approbation en
tant que substance active a utilisé dans
les produits phytopharmaceutiques des
conclusions synonyme de scandale pour l'
ong générations futures d'autant qu'elle
le rappel l'herbicide est classé
cancérigène probable et cela depuis 2015
par le centre international de recherche
sur le cancer
le crc rattaché à l'om s il est vraiment
décevant de voir aujourd'hui le groupe
de pays en charge de la réévaluation du
glyphosate dont la france
reprendre la même litanie de l'innocuité
du glyphosate
alors que le poids des preuves
scientifiques est accablant pour cette
molécule comme le rappelait les
scientifiques du cnrc en 2015
mais nous sommes au tout début du
processus et générations futures ainsi
que toutes les ong du réseau pesticide
action network europe vont maintenant
épluché ce rapport et le critiquer en
détail à la lumière des données
scientifiques disponibles montrant les
effets cancérogènes et génotoxique du
glyphosate
il est plus que temps de se débarrasser
de cet herbicide dangereux en europe et
en france
même son de cloche du côté de l'alliance
pour la santé et l'environnement
pour cette organisation qui regroupe de
nombreuses associations
cette décision pose clairement la
question de l'indépendance des
la scion fait sur les produits comme le
glyphosate l'annoncent d'aujourd'hui sur
la sécurité du glyphosate est un grand
pas en arrière et met en lumière les
questions qui subsistent quant à
l'objectivité et à l'indépendance de
l'évaluation de la sécurité des
pesticides par l'europe pour rappel le
glyphosate l herbicide le plus utilisé
dans le monde et a été une nouvelle fois
autorisée au sein de l'union européenne
en 2017 pour une durée de cinq ans
jusqu'en 2022 donc après examen du
rapport l'autorité européenne de
sécurité des aliments et l'agencé
européenne des produits chimiques vont
organiser des consultations ouvertes au
public en septembre les deux entités
s'exprimeront ensuite sur les domaines
qui les concernent
puis enfin reviendra à la commission
européenne de statuer sur le
renouvellement ou non de l'autorisation
du glyphosate
elle pourra en parler non seulement avec
gilles rivière beckstein fondateur de la
revue agriculture et environnement
hauteur de glyphosate l'impossible des
débats aux éditions lepublieur bonsoir
gilles bridier avec c'est merci d'être
avec nous l'impossible débat est trop
niais parce que la conclusion du rapport
est clair aucune propriété
toxicologiques
on revient pas clairement en arrière
c'est un débat qui tourne en boucle
écoutez moi je pense que pas du tout
reconnaît pas les leurs le progrès là on
voit clairement que le discours de
françois dérec et de ses zones j'ai
complètement dépassé il se base sur une
étude du cirque de 2015 qui d'ailleurs
n'a pas prouvés ni démontrés que le
glyphosate était cancérigène
puisqu'il dit que c'est grand c'est vrai
le probable depuis vous avez trois
agences sanitaires à l'échelle mondiale
qui se sont prononcés les ça s'est
prononcé en 2017 en dix ans en recyclant
refus temps là quand serge était
glyphosate
vous avez le pea bockel agences
sanitaires américaines qui est arrivé
aux mêmes conclusions et ensuite de
kanata qui viendrait
né le 10 face à en ce qui concerne cette
nouvelle étude prétendre que les gens
n'ont pas bien fait leur boulot c'est
que même fort de café
pour la première fois vous avez quatre
états membres
quatre états membres qui ont mis à
l'heure dite à la disposition de l'union
européenne leurs agences sanitaires
il s'agit de la france de l'inde cesse
donc il s'agit de des pays-bas de la
suède de la hongrie tous ces
scientifiques se sont donc réunis pour
travailler la question et vous comprenez
bien vous ne l'imaginez pas une seconde
qu'ils n'ont pas pris connaissance de
toutes les données dont dispose le
cirque dont dispose et dossiers pendants
2015 et donc en ayant pris toutes les
données toutes les mises à jour qui
existent aujourd'hui que disent ils ils
disent tout simplement avec un rapport
qui fait plus de onze mille pages que
finalement ben non ce n'est pas un
produit qui est cancérigène
ce qu on a toujours sur en fait si bien
la seule agence qui a prétendu le
contraire
c'est le site on lui disait qu'il disait
que c'était quand ce gel probable donc
on voit bien que aujourd'hui françois
dérec et toutes ces associations
écologiques qui ont fait le buzz est un
symbole sont mis dans un coin une offre
uniquement se raccrocher quand même
chose qu'à cette étude de but cirque qui
date de 2015
mais bon il faut maintenant revenir à la
raison
il est clair que cette histoire le vrai
scandale du glyphosate s'est fait une
manipulation médiatique qui a eu lieu
pour faire croire à l'opinion publique
que ce produit est cancérigène et sam
bot mon livre là l'esprit qui très
clairement c'est une opération de gros
shows américains
c'est une opération qui a été mis en
place par l'est les avocats américains
qui se sont saisi de cette question pour
essayer d'obtenir des milliards de
dollars à paris le bailleur et même
peut-être réussir mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec la santé du tout et je tiens
aussi à ce dîner le fait qu' il n'y a
aucun pays dans le monde aujourd'hui aux
états-unis au canada et qui a
interdit le glyphosate dont la france ou
l'europe seraient les seuls à le faire
sur la base d'une étude de 2015 du
cirque et qui dit pas qui dit pas grand
chose il faut être sérieux aujourd'hui
vous avez ces quatre pays
ces quatre agences qui ont tranché la
question et comme le titre correctement
le monde ça donne une la voix collerez
homologation de cette molécule
et c'est une très bonne chose parce que
c'est un des produits les moins toxiques
pour la santé et les moins toxiques pour
l'environnement
je savais qu'ils le sont quand même un
peu à défaut d'être cancérigènes il ya
quand même une forme de toxicité c'est
un pesticide
c'est à dire by side ce sont des
produits qui sont qui ont donc suscité
par définition c'est un c'est un produit
qui était mis en place pour éliminer les
mauvaises herbes pour éliminer a donc
évidemment qu'il est au xi cité mais
comme tout produit les l'agriculture
biologique utilisent des produits qui
sont toxiques comme à l'aller victoire
conventionnelle la péta question des
toxicités n'est pas un problème
la question c'est est-ce que c'est une
toxicité qui est qui est maîtrisable qui
reste piet qui est acceptable
et surtout est-ce que c'est une toxicité
pour l'homme et l'a fait clair pas ce
n'est pas le cas mais bien entendu on ne
déversent pas sur des champs de la de la
confiture donc tuer nos méninges chère
madame c'est timide ont donc oui c'est
un produit toxique
je vous pose la question vous connaissez
effectivement le sujet certainement
mieux que tout le monde mais il ya quand
même une défiance est parfois une manque
de la monte de confiance ont simplement
de l'opinion publique envers ces
rapports retrouvons dans les instances
européennes
ça ne vous interpelle pas justement ce
manque de confiance
la faute à qui est cette étude cette
manipulation dont vous parlez il n'ya
que sa part que ce soit voilà on nous
dit pas toujours toute la vérité sans
verser dans le complotisme à loin de moi
cette idée mais voilà on ne dit pas la
vérité on se rend compte après que les
choses étaient dangereuses écoutez je
pense qu'on a vu tout ce complotisme
prendre une telle enclos où tout des
questions des vaccins je crois que la
population a finalement a finalement
bien compris que les agences sanitaires
qui sont en charge de notre santé sont
très attention il ya aucune raison celui
que ces mêmes agences sanitaires
n'agissent pas de la même manière
pour des questions de cet ordre là
n'oubliez pas que nous avons mis en
place les agences sanitaires pour
garantir la sécurité de nos citoyens
ce sont des agences qui sont financés
par les états se sont pas défilés des
agences qui sont financés parler parler
parler firme est le but de ces agences
est justement de voir s'il n'y aurait
pas eu de la part de la firme quelconque
manque une manipulation et c'est donc ce
sont des gens qui sont formés pour
regarder si justement tout a été fait
correctement
hélas pour qu'il n'y ait pas de doute
cette fois ci on a mis quatre agences de
quatre pays différents
mais que voulez-vous du choc vous pensez
franchement c'est qu'elle ne va rien
j'ai l'impression qu'on va chercher
comment faire voilà je vois que je pose
des questions être assurée par le fait
que ce ses 4 agences et qu'ils arrêtent
aboutissent exactement aux mêmes
conclusions que d'autres agences dans le
reste du monde
un moment donné il faut quand même ne
pas refaire confiance à toutes ses
agences à ce moment là on fait confiance
à qui doit on n'est pas oui c'est la
même logique que pour le pour le vaccin
quelque part les gens qui quittent des
gens qui pensent que les que derrière
tout ça c'est du gros business etc
on arrive à jamais de convaincre mais
les gens qui sont des zones à risque en
tout cas quand même différent même si on
comprend votre idée mais merci gilles
rivière avec stand avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france ce soir
matthew rester avec nous dans quelques
instants
dron sur l'éventualité d'une vaccination
obligatoire en france notamment pour les
soignants l'idée progresse alors
qu'olivier ferrand a lancé un appel
solennel aujourd'hui c'est personnel
époux cvo krolu tour de france des
manuels macron déplacement aujourd'hui
dans les hauts de france à trois jours
du premier tour des régionales
[Musique]
et
m
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
dans toutes les entreprises du cac 40
ont perçu des aides publiques
une très grande majorité a et va verser
des dividendes à ses actionnaires
ont-ils profité du système où le système
les at il un peu aidés ou verse des
aides à des gens qui n'en ont pas besoin
c'est pas la première fois que l'état
fait des choses idiotes
c'est édifiant mais c'est pas illégal si
vous commencez à verser des subventions
à certains secteurs économiques point de
vue sectoriel et pas un autre
il ya ce qu'on appelle un rupture
d'équité d'égalité le fait est qu'on
aurait très bien pu mettre des
conditions mais qu'on savait de toute
façon c'était pas tenable vous pouvez
pas prêter de l'argent à une boîte en
faillite comme air france et lui dire
mais si je te prête de l'argent tu ne
peux pas y censier de du du personnel ça
ne tient pas debout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique
l'eau une vaccination à l'est une
vaccination savez la vaccination ce
n'est pas elle n'a pas commencé avec la
movida
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les production de
vaccins ou et le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup danger sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
importants ainsi que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc vie de 19 pour en finir avec
justement la dépendance vis-à-vis des
laboratoires à l'étranger que ça soit le
sénégal le nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition
l'avoir amené la générale de la santé
publique au toc des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
m
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les numéros uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas la
double hic parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir invité
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise je
pense ça a été bien de continuer le
football pour s'évader à eux aussi au
niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligne et tout ce qui est au niveau
social surtout au niveau culture et quel
regard portez-vous sur toutes ces années
à monaco à la juventus en équipe de
france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et nantes surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est touchant
[Musique]
on vend soir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 17 juin le port
du masque en extérieur n'est plus
obligatoire depuis aujourd'hui sauf dans
certains cas à fin du couvre-feu
également dès dimanche et cette porte
entrouverte aujourd'hui par le ministre
de la santé l'éventualité d'une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants notamment en ehpad
olivier ferrand lance un appel alors
doit-on imposer une piqûre aux soignants
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
si la france n'a pas encore tranché sur
la vaccination obligatoire des soignants
c'est chose faite
en outre manche depuis hier une décision
sans doute motivée par l'inquiétante
reprise épidémies et aux variants delta
beaucoup plus contagieux les autorités
sanitaires britanniques ont enregistré
aujourd'hui plus de dix mille 4 qu'ovide
une première depuis février dernier
laurent gbagbo de retour en côte
d'ivoire définitivement acquittés par la
cour pénale internationale l'ancien
président ivoirien est arrivé tout à
l'heure à l'aéroport d'abidjan en près
de dix ans d'absence
il a été acclamé à sa descente d'avion
par des centaines de partisans celle qui
avait pu avoir accès à l'aéroport
[Musique]
une sensation que l'on avait presque
oublié sortir dehors sans masque c'est
possible depuis ce matin certains l'ont
même oublié la décision était annoncée
hier par jean castex
le premier ministre estime que les
conditions sanitaires sont réunies pour
lever certaines restrictions
autre bonne surprise le couvre feu prend
fin dès dimanche les détails de mehdi et
ski fis nous vivons un moment important
à un moment heureux
de retour à une forme de vie normale un
moment heureux voilà comment le premier
ministre qualifie la levée d'une
restriction en place dans le pays depuis
juillet dernier celle du port du masque
obligatoire en extérieur dans certaines
circonstances
une annonce qui était attendue à l'issue
du conseil des ministres et qui réjouit
des français nous allons lever
l'obligation générale du port du masque
un extérieur le port du max années
steria heures ne sera donc plus
obligatoire sauf dans certaines
circonstances quand on se regroupe
quand on se trouve dans un lieu bondé
une files d'attentes sur un marché ou
encore dans les tribunes d'un stade
au delà la fin du port du masque
obligatoire une autre mesure disparaît
dès ce dimanche alors qu'elle était en
place depuis octobre 2020 le couvre-feu
sur le territoire national une décision
qui intervient dix jours avant la date
prévue
le couvre-feu à 23 heures qui devait
vous le savez s'appliquer jusqu'au 30
juin cessera de s'appliquer à compter de
ce dimanche soit dix jours avant la date
prévue
la levée de ces restrictions en place
depuis l'année dernière
interviennent alors qu'une dizaine de
cas du variant delta ont été détectés
dans l'essonne ce mardi ce d'après
l'agencé régionale de santé
malgré la découverte de ce cluster une
partie de l'opposition estiment que le
gouvernement reste encore trop prudent
et exige de lui d'aller plus loin à
propos des restrictions antico vide
castex dit qu'il remettra toutes les
restrictions si l'épidémie repart cette
logique et sans fin royaume-uni ça
repart
ici on dit déjà quatrième vague à la
rentrée hashtag masque faim partout
extérieures et intérieures pas juste des
accommodements et fin du passé ni terre
j'ai ainsi fait il est donc vraiment
j'invite tous nos concitoyens ont
continué de se faire vacciner
elle est la vaccination qui est le seul
moyen durablement de combattre cette
épidémie aurait continué ensuite à
avancer les choses étape par étape
comment la prime le gouvernement décide
de lever ces restrictions alors que les
chiffres de la pandémie sont en
constante baisse dans l'hexagone avec un
nombre de personnes en réanimation qui
passe sous la barre des 2000 malades
d'après co by traqueur un
assouplissement des mesures restrictives
annoncé quelques jours avant le premier
tour des élections régionales
et face aux bons chiffres emmanuel
macron n'a pas manqué de se féliciter de
sa bonne stratégie le chef de l'état qui
était en visite aujourd'hui à château
thierry en picardie a rappelé ses
nouveaux objectifs de lutte contre
locaux vides étendre la vaccination aux
personnes les plus éloignées des soins
et la sueur et à toutes les personnes
vulnérables et ceux qui les entourent
écoutez je pense que la logique serait
que nous sommes et approche qui est la
nôtre continue d'être de jouer sur
l'adhésion
l'intelligence la responsabilité
maintenant notre travail est d'aller
convaincre d'aller aussi vers nos
concitoyens qui sont les plus loin du
soin dans les semaines qui viennent
je le dis parce que vous avez beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui sont dans des
situations plus fragile plus précaires
qui ont parfois autant besoin que vous
et moi de se faire vacciner et qui sont
n'ont pas de médecin référent qui n'ont
pas le même accès à l'information vous à
falloir aller les chercher ce qu'on a
comme en c1 depuis début février
j'ai des gens qui en effet continuer à
douter donc c'est ce travail de
conviction qu'elle je crois davantage
il ya des situations par contre que nous
souhaitons régler durant l'été c'est
celle des établissements en particulier
accueillant des personnes en situation
de grande fragilité
les ehpad et maisons de retraite là il
est très clair qu'il faut vraiment une
mobilisation pour qui un maximum des
personnels soignants qui puissent être
vaccinés est toujours du côté de la
vaccination livier véran agite la menace
d'une vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants notamment en ehpad le ministre
de la santé qui lance un appel solennel
et fait valoir qu'on ne prendra pas le
risque à la rentrée d'exposer les
résidents à une menace d'infection alors
faut-il à rendre obligatoire cette
vaccination pour les soignants c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec me nommer garbade chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière merci bruno meyer va naître
avec nous à vos côtés bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes bonsoir bertrand
legrand alors moins de 50 % de personnel
soignant on n'est pas de vacciner alors
qu'il était prioritaire on le rappelle
olivier verront le ministre de la santé
tire la sonnette d'alarmé écoutez je
fais vraiment un appel solennel aux
soignants qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
pour qu'il franchisse le cap c'est
important ils ne peuvent pas être moins
vacciner que la population générale
alors clairement à brno m'égare ban
faut-il rendre obligatoire et
obligatoire cette vaccination pour les
personnes au contact des plus fragiles
selon vous
j'allais dire il faut d'abord commencer
par de la pédagogie rappelé évidemment
l'importance de la vaccination
le fait que le vaccin protège contre les
formes graves de lakovic 19 et surtout
réduit de façon drastique la
contamination et de ce fait évidemment
tout soignants se doit évidemment de
protéger les patients dont il a la
charge est à mon sens se doit donc de se
faire vacciner si effectivement dans
quelques jours ou semaines ou voit qu'il
ya une stagnation du nombre de soignants
vacciner je crois qu'effectivement il
faudra rendre la vaccination obligatoire
il n'est pas acceptable
évidemment que à nouveau en septembre
octobre
lakovic 19 redevienne la premières
causes d'infections nosocomiales à
l'hôpital et entraîne le décès des
personnes les plus fragiles notamment
des pannes ailleurs bertrand legrand
faire de la pédagogie auprès des
personnes certainement qui sont le plus
informé ça paraît un petit peu bizarre
n'est-ce pas je pense que derrière le
chiffre de soignants ou derrière la le
conglomérat de soignants on range des
réalités qui sont bien différentes et
que dans les catégories de soignants on
a des taux de vaccinations qui sont très
différents on sait que chez les
présentes dans les médecins libéraux
on est à largement plus de 85 % de
personnes vaccinées et que ceux qui sont
pas vaccinés sont en attente de plus
alors se faire vacciner tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont été contaminés c'est à
peu près la même situation chez
infirmiers et par contre on a une chose
qui existe et c'est malheureusement ce
que moi je vis aussi dans mon cabinet
les patients les plus défavorisés sont
aussi ceux qui sont le plus rétif à la
vaccination
et je vous rappelle que dans les ehpad
c'est mal payés le travail est difficile
et que nous avons deux dans des
personnels qui sont vraiment entrés en
situation de précarité et donc on est
vraiment dans une population qui est
parfaitement ciblée c'est une population
qui est rétive à la vaccination quelle
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs et c'est pas
très étonnant ce chiffre ce qui est très
étonnant c'est l'absence en fait le
politiquement correct de ne jamais dire
la réalité des choses est la vraie
réalité des choses c'est que dans les
ehpad les gens sont très mal payés pour
un travail très difficile et comprend
des gens avec un milieu
j'irai culturel qui est trop bas par
rapport au travail qu'on leur demande de
faire ça c'est une réalité et on en
arrive à des situations où effectivement
on pourrait se retrouver comme en
belgique ou des situations de variants
delta se développent dans des ehpad et
on connaissait les situations
dramatiques que ça va porter dont il est
très important de faire de la pédagogie
auprès de ces gens là et la pédagogie
prêter gens là elle passe par leur
médecin traitant et non pas par des
grands centres de vaccination qui sont
trop informel et qui veut dire lequel
n'a pas assez de confiance et bruno
megaman de choses importantes dans ce
vient de nous dire bertrand legrand tout
d'abord cet écart entre le personnel
soignant en ehpad et les professionnels
libéraux en c'est à dire on vilain qui
sont davantage vacciner et l'explication
qu'avant sur le docteur le grand voile à
des personnels peut-être défavorisés
socialement parlant est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette explication ce
diagnostic alors oui effectivement on
note bien un différentiel du taux de
vaccination entre les différents
personnels soignants les médecins à
l'hôpital sont vaccinés pour plus de 90%
al'inverse les aides soignants les
brancardiers le sont à peine à 50 %
malgré tout tout ce personnel quel que
soit son origine sociale
quel que soit son rôle dans la chaîne de
soins va être en contact avec le patient
et donc risque bien sûr de le contaminer
il faut donc évidemment dans un premier
temps user de pédagogie d'explication
j'entends tout à fait bien sûr qu'il lui
faille réexpliqué peut-être à certaines
personnel moins susceptibles d'avoir
bien compris les choses
l'intérêt de la vaccination maintenant à
mon sens je dirais même si en provenance
peut-être d'un milieu social un peu plus
défavorisés on a moins accès à
l'information
il n'y a pas de raison que le fait
d'être moins payés entraîne
l'acceptation d'être non vaccinés à la
casse je suis bien sûr tout à fait
d'accord que l'ensemble du personnel
soignant devrait payer la juste hauteur
de son travail et je suis d'accord que
les professions les moins qualifiés sont
très mal payés à l'hôpital pourtant ils
sont indispensables et on a vu qu'avec
la crise ça a été le point clé
évidemment qui a bloqué le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital public
non je voudrais vous faire réagir sur la
vie de l'académie de médecine qui
semblait assez raccord avec le ministre
de la santé qui souhaiteraient
certainement rendre obligatoire cette
vaccination écouter la population des
soignants est à l'origine de 34 % des
cas groupés d'infections nosocomiales
asra skov 2 considérant que l'hésitation
vaccinale éthiquement inacceptable chez
les soignants l'académie nationale de
médecine recommande de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination contre la
copie de 19 pour tous les professionnels
de santé la bertrand legrand
l'hésitation en vaccinale est
éthiquement inacceptable chez les
soignants il ya un petit côté
moralisateur dans cette sortie de
l'académie de
de médecine qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous en tout cas de cette approche tout
à fait raison c'est ce que je rappelle
systématiquement au grand carbet aux
expédients conséquent j'en ai dans mon
cabinet on peut pas prendre le risque de
contaminer nos propres patients et ils
en sont conscients et après le besoin de
formation du personnel le moins
qualifiés est extrêmement important et
si on regarde les budgets de formation
sont ils correctement à louer on s'il
priorités ont été été priorisés sur des
personnels qui ont une forte valeur
ajoutée dans l'anodin à les hôpitaux
dans les ehpad et même dans le monde
libéral c'est une vraie question je
pense que on manque d'investissements
pour rendre attractif les métiers mais
plus difficile de l'hôpital le paiement
c'est une chose la formation c'est une
chose la qualité delà du niveau de
formation de nausées des deux aides
soignants de nous regardiez on a
aujourd'hui on a tellement besoin de
main d'oeuvre que l'on accepte des
personnes qui dont on pourrait se poser
la question de savoir si leur place est
encore dans le personnel soignant si
elle refuse de se vacciner c'est très
clairement la question qui se pose c'est
bruno ménard man en tout cas l'académie
ne fait pas de distinction elle parle de
vraiment de tous les soignants
je sens c'est que royaume uni c'est
obligatoire pour les pour les personnels
en ehpad uniquement cette pose quand
même une question sur les libertés
individuelles de force et de contraindre
les gens à se faire vacciner est ce
qu'il faut aller à défaut de pédagogie
en tout cas si la pédagogie
ne va pas ne marche pas jusqu'au bout
est-ce qu'il faudra la rendre
obligatoire et sa prospère une question
de liberté individuelle alors j'allais
dire autant ça peut le poser à l'échelle
de la population générale je vous
rappelle que la cape de l'académie de
médecine a même recommandé la
vaccination obligatoire pour l'ensemble
des adultes
par contre pour un soignant je crois là
il ya des devoirs
on a choisi d'être soignant il y à un
certain nombre de devoirs qui nous
incombe
et si on ne souhaite pas les remplir on
n'a qu'à sortir du système de soins est
allé faire un autre travail
je crois que la première le premier
devoir d'un soignant et de ne pas
aggraver la situation de son patient et
de se donner le maximum des moyens pour
améliorer sa situation
malheureusement dans beaucoup de cas
nous sommes démunis car la médecine est
incapable de soigner toutes les maladies
c'est pas pour autant évidemment qu'il
faut de nuire aux patients que l'on a
entre les mains
donc je crois que la vaccination contre
la coved effectivement s'impose à nous
tous je crois on peut encore donner
quelques jours ou semaines pour
convaincre et pour laisser le temps car
je suis d'accord un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont peut-être été
infectées au cours de cette dernière
vague attendent encore les trois mois
nécessaires pour se faire vacciner
mais passé un certain délai je crois
qu'il faudra rendre les choses
obligatoire pour éviter à nouveau une
catastrophe dans les ehpad et les
hôpitaux en septembre-octobre et
bertrand legrand est aussi la question
de de l'astra et les cas on se souvient
qu'au départ on voulait à vacciner les
soignants avec ce sérum qui n'a pas eu
toujours bonne presse et on entendait
moi je n'ai entendu certains médecins
nous dit on va manger pas envie d'être à
deux jours voilà avec 40 de fièvre au
lit avec ses effets secondaires qui
étaient parfois connu pour astrazeneca
est ce que les choses peuvent évoluer de
ce point de vue là si on choisit un
autre vaccin pour ces soignants
aujourd'hui les soignants sont très
majoritairement des personnes de moins
de 55 ans donc c'est heureusement ça n'a
pas beaucoup changé
du coup elles ne sont pas éligibles à
l'astra zeneca ou janssen elles ne sont
éligibles comme modern art où oprisor
donc tu as de ce problème là il est
réglé à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
après personnellement je me suis vacciné
à l'astra je vais très bien et je suis
toujours vivant comme vous pouvez le
voir il ya pas de problème crème la
majorité de mes confrères qui se sont
vaccinés à l'astra bien survivre on a eu
un peu de chefs bon on a été travaillé
quand même c'est pas dramatique
bruno mega man c'est un bon signal quand
même ça pose question
quel message envoyé aux antilles vax
quand on voit que beaucoup de soignants
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
est ce qu'on connaît leurs vraies
motivations profondes est ce qu'il ya
une méfiance envers le vaccin alors je
pense que la majorité des personnes
soignantes qui ne se sont pas encore
fait vacciner sont en fait plutôt dans
la tente que vraiment dans la méfiance
complète vis-à-vis du vaccin
à mon sens une très grosse partie de ces
personnes vont se faire vacciner
évidemment il persistera une infime
minorité de personnes vaccinaux
sceptiques voire militant contre la
vaccination mais ça reste vraiment une
infime minorité à la marge il faut
rappeler qu effectivement à partir de
septembre octobre le virus var circuler
et c'est d'ailleurs essentiellement les
souches les plus contagieuses voire
peut-être si de nouvelles souches
apparaissait dé souche plus virulente
qui vont circuler
or nous tous allons évidemment adopter
un mode de vie quasi normale car la très
grosse majorité des adultes sera vacciné
les lieux d'interactions sociales les
restaurants les cafés les bars seront
ouverts or les personnes non vaccinées
devront en alternative mettre
systématiquement le masque partout et
conserver la distanciation sociale
malheureusement ils ne le feront pas
car évidemment ils adopteront le mode de
vie de ceux qui les entourent
c'est à dire des personnes vaccinées il
courant le risque d'être contaminé et de
venir à l'hôpital et de surcharger les
services d urgence et de réanimation et
malheureusement de décéder il faut
rappeler à nouveau la vaccination et
d'avant avant toute chose une protection
individuelle de la personne qui se fait
vacciner
en tout cas il ya beaucoup de colère
chez les personnels
et n'y ont pas forcément que dans les
ehpad je vous propose d'écouter cette
réaction du collectif inter blog sur sur
les réseaux sociaux
la vaccination est un moyen mais pas le
seul
à quand l'application de l'obligation de
protection maximale envers les soignants
avec des masques ffp2 qualité et
sécurité maximale et non des cas n 95
chinois non conformes ou avec des
produits toxiques
on est sept cette colère et ses
questionnements bertrand legrand
quand on en avait besoin on en a pas eu
et certains sont restés sur 7 sur cette
notion m'ont fait bien en fait d un
moment donné où s'opposer tout le temps
c'est très bien mais il ya un moment où
il faut quand même regarder les choses
aujourd'hui on a plus de problème de
masquer ce serait complètement faux de
dire qu'on n'a pas de masque à
disposition et d'ailleurs je me demande
bien encore pourquoi on dérembourse etc
etc
il ya un moment donné où effectivement
on est majoritaire à être vaccinés
la majorité des français valette maxime
et la majorité des français ont fait les
efforts qu'il fallait pour préserver la
génération du dessus combien de temps
encore on va faire des efforts
financiers pour des gens qui refusent la
vaccination un moment donné ces gens
doivent être responsables de ce qu'ils
font et la responsabilité quand on ne se
vaccinent pas c'est évidemment qu'on ne
travaille pas dans un milieu à risque la
deuxième responsabilité c'est qu'on
prend en charge ses propres choix et je
les invite donc à réfléchir aussi à tout
ce qu'ils font peser sur la france par
ses romans donné on peut pas demander la
liberté et ne pas assumer ses devoirs et
des choses qui incombe à la liberté
merci beaucoup vous nommez gardanne et
bertrand legrand d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce que ça fasse ce soir merci à
vous le tour de france des manuels
macron continue avec un voyage dans
l'aisne aujourd'hui le président qui a
annoncé et lancer la lecture comme
grande cause nationale de l'été 2021 et
et 2022
le chef de l'état qui poursuit ses
déplacements pour aller prendre le pouls
des français à seulement trois jours du
premier tour des régionales
1 pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialise bonsoir alexis
poulain
être avec nous alors emmanuel macron qui
est de retour sur le terrain et s'auto
félicite de la stratégie de
déconfinement pourtant encore un petit
peu flou oui alors s'auto féliciter
c'est un d une des grandes qualités d'
emmanuel macron il est toujours très
content de ce qu'il fait tout comme le
gouvernement
et c'est vrai que on l'a vu devant des
élèves un client pourtant poser la
question alors est-ce que ça va depuis
la claque que vous avez prises en mise
en scène encore une fois cette fois ci
dans une école
et puis ces déambulations du promeneur
de l'elysée pour dire que tout va très
bien madame la marquise et qu'il a géré
cette crise sanitaire de manière
exceptionnelle comparé au reste des
leaders mondiaux et que lui décidément
le meilleur quelle chance nous avons
mais en réalité tout ça est très floue
comme vous venez de le dire à la fois
sur la le rythme de la vaccination n'a
pu vraiment les chiffres sur les
premiers vaccinés et puis ceux qui ont
la vaccination total mais également sur
ses dates qui ont totalement sauter la
fin du couvre-feu
la la la fin de toutes les barrières qui
avait parce que finalement la bamboche a
gagné trois jours de suite que les
jeunes se réunissaient sur les pelouse
en plein coeur de paris
et là la police ne peut plus rien faire
et puis des remontées de terrain qui
disait évidemment les gens en ont assez
les restaurateurs notamment qui ouvrait
et qui voyait bien que à 23 heures c'est
impossible de faire partir les gens pour
qu'ils rentrent chez eux donc il a fallu
céder finalement à la volonté populaire
qui était de d'arrêter avec ces mesures
de restriction non pas sanitaire ahmed
de restriction liberticide qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le contrôle d'un virus
c'est la fin du masque en extérieur
aussi et pourtant ça fait des mois que
l'on sait que le masque en extérieur ne
sert à rien dans la plupart des
situations quand vous êtes seul dans une
rue où très peu nombreux dans une rue
évidemment le masque ne sert à rien mais
il fallait quand même le tenir pour que
l'exécutif ne perde pas la face passe à
ces mesures de privation des libertés
puis dernière aberration qui tombe le
masque des plus jeunes les enfants dans
les cours de récréation à 6 ans est bien
là aussi il tombe il a fallu quelques
heures de décalage pour qu'ils se
rendent compte du décalage énorme entre
la volonté des politiques liberticides
et la volonté de liberté des populations
qui n'ont peu
plus finalement de ces mesures dont on
peut critiquer le bien-fondé
scientifique puisque nous n'avons aucune
preuve aujourd'hui d'un couvre-feu plus
efficace à 19h à 21h à 23h ou pas du
tout en l'occurrence le pas du tout va
nous permettre de vivre un été des
confiné alors après certains sont déjà
en train de nous parler de quatrième
vague 1 reste à savoir si elle arrivera
ou pas mais pour ce qui est de la
stratégie des malades macron elle a été
cette fois-ci dicté par la rue mais la
question qu'on peut se poser alexis la
communication présidentielle at elle
pour objectif de pousser les candidats
rêvent aux régionales ou est ce une
surenchère de sortie de crise
alors c'est vrai que en ce moment
emmanuel macron et partout on le voit à
tous les sommaires il prend la parole
sur tous les sujets aujourd'hui ils
discutaient poésie littérature et
peinture avec fabrice luchini un allant
même jusqu'à le comparer rimbaud un
peintre classique
donc tout est possible pour le promeneur
de l'elysée il ya un côté psychédélique
dans cette communication qui veut
toucher tous les publics
tout le temps à la fois les publics les
plus jeunes c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il lève les restrictions sanitaires
c'est un peu dans l'idée de dire ça y
est vous avez gagné
je vous ai entendu les puits et il faut
ne pas oublier les régionales alors
emmanuel macron s'en défend il dit bien
qu'il ne veut surtout pas interférer
dans les élections régionales mais il
est le seul aujourd'hui qui peut prendre
la parole de cette façon là qu'on perd
nos ministres qui ont un devoir de
réserve
vu que nous sommes dans une semaine
électorale donc clairement il est là
pour pousser les candidatures des
candidats lrm à la fois pour montrer
qu'ils existent les faire connaître
certains sont encore en déficit de
notoriété publique
donc ça permet de les pousser et
d'affaiblir soient les candidats aient
l'air typiquement xavier bertrand qui
est une cible dans la région nord pour
pour le laisser y est de l'affaiblir
face à un rassemblent nationale qui est
très fort avec l'envoi de ministres
comme monsieur dupont moretti mise de la
justice qui passe tous ses week-ends
maintenant à faire campagne bien habillé
pour expliquer qu'il est là pour les
habitants de la région est donc
clairement il y à là cette volonté de
prendre la main et d'essayer de pousser
ces candidatures sans le dire parce que
le score de la république en marche
risque d'être calamiteux également pour
ces régionales donc si les vitres à une
bérézina comme pour les municipales
ce ne sera pas non plus un plébiscite
populaire quel agenda
finalement celui emmanuel macron est ce
qu'il reste pour reprendre une formule 1
est ce qu'il reste le maître des
horloges
alors c'est ainsi qu'il s'était présenté
lors de son élection 1 en disant c'est
moi qui décide et puis très vite lors le
jeu s'est déréglé avec la sphère benalla
par exemple sur la place de la
contrescarpe est là toute la machine
s'est déréglée
il a voulu être le maître les horloges
avec la réforme des retraites en
utilisant le 49 3 en allant là encore
contre l'avis des partenaires sociaux
il a voulu être le maître des horloges
contre les gilets jaunes avec ce grand
débat qui a privatisé la parole un
finalement où il a été monologue est
partout en france et empêcher les
cahiers de doléances de devenir
finalement des réelles cahier de
doléances donc oui clairement son agenda
personnel est celui de maintenant donner
le pouls donné le tempo de 2022 et
d'assurer qu'il puisse rentrer en
campagne le plus tard possible et avec
le meilleur bilan possible hélas toute
cette communication frénétique qu'on a
vu ces derniers jours c'est d'assurer
que dans l'esprit des français il
restera comme le sauveur du pays et le
président qui a le mieux géré la crise
sanitaire même s'il n'ya plus de cent
dix mille morts même si on a menti le
gouvernement a menti sur les masques au
début de cette crise même si la
vaccination au début de la campagne a
été un fiasco
même si il y encore beaucoup de fous
comme je le disais sur ceux des
confinement qui ressemble très fort
déconfinement de 2020 où ça a été un
grand lâcher prise pendant tout l'été
là on a l'impression qu'il ya des dates
que tout ça est très réglée olivier
verrons nous dit que les discothèques
rouvriront en juillet mais non on a
l'impression que ça y est c'est fini
pour deux mois trois mois
et puis comme je vous le disais certains
nous parlent déjà quatrième vague et
peut-être qu emmanuel macron a déjà en
tête
l'horlogerie de la rentrée durant
campagne qui sera évidemment à la
rentrée de septembre pour tous les
candidats les nouveaux candidats qui
vont se déclarer à ce moment là et puis
clairement une fois les régionales
passées que certains parlent aujourd'hui
d'un remaniement ministériel
ça reste à voir mais il y a des noms qui
circulent et il se pourrait évidemment
qu'en fonction des scores de la
république en marche le gouvernement
change de tête échange même de ministre
pendant un temps pour préparer la
dernière année qui sera une année de
campagne d' emmanuel macron merci
beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir été avec
nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la reprise de
l'épidémie aubriot muni dix mille cas
ont été enregistrés en 24 heures une
première depuis février dernier en cause
le variant delta plus contagieux et puis
nous parlerons du retour de laurent
gbagbo en côte d'ivoire l'ancien
président ivoirien est arrivé tout à
l'heure à abidjan ont définitivement
acquittés par la cour pénale
internationale
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes à chez
vox harry allons faire connaissance vous
avez choisi le jour alors je suis arrivé
en 2005 pour étudier dernière poche l'an
concept et en 2011 le monde manque pas
un petit peu non ah oui c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylé
fallu les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la courge
aussi nos mii vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois 21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez alors que la france
ed confine le variant delta inquiète
on compte plus de dix mille cas en 24
heures au royaume uni une première
depuis février dernier l'allègement des
restrictions interroge mais l'objectif
de ce déconfinement rapide est avant
tout de pouvoir vacciner rapidement
david khalifa la course à l'immunité est
lancé objectif pour l'exécutif éviter le
scénario britannique
le royaume uni est contraint de
repousser la dernière étape de son
déconfinement du 21 juin au 19 juillet
en grande partie dû aux variants delta
détecté dans 74 pays
le variant indien continue de se
propager faisant craindre qu'il ne
devienne la souche la plus dominante
dans le monde
ces caractéristiques plus contagieux
mais surtout plus discret les symptômes
s'apparentent beaucoup plus un rhume cas
une grosse grippe ce qui fait baisser la
vigilance de ses porteurs outre-manche
le variant delta n'a pas été considéré à
sa juste mesure faisant ainsi augmenter
les hospitalisations de 50% la faute du
gouvernement qui a manqué de vigilance
yes we can tous les éléments de preuve
indiquent que non pourtant été sur la
liste rouge a raison mais elle n a pas
été directement mis sur cette piste
rouge et toute personne intelligente
comprend qu'elle n'a pas été mis sur la
liste rouge car le premier ministre
bruce thompson
je mets avaient prévu un voyage en inde
pour rencontrer le premier ministre
musulman et 7 c'est regrettable
objectif du gouvernement ne pas
reproduire les mêmes erreurs en france
car la situation peut vite dégénérer le
variant delta se propageant déjà à
grande vitesse notamment dans les landes
où ils représentent 30% des
contaminations
olivier ferrand averti actuellement en
france 2 à 4%
les tests que nous prient blond donc des
tests positifs chez les français
correspond de diva payant un bien ce qui
représente quand même je vous donne une
fourchette assez large mais de l'ordre
de 50 à 150 nouveaux diagnostics de
variants delta dans notre pays je vous
dis cela évidemment pour vous enjoindre
à ne pas relâcher notre vigilance
collective
j'ai certainement pas le moment de ne
pas relâcher la vigilance collective et
surtout maintenir le rythme de la
vaccination pour éviter une quatrième
vague en septembre alain fischer le
monsieur vaccin du gouvernement estime à
90 % le taux de couverture vaccinale
pour faire face à l'arrivée de ce
variant indien d'où les prises de
positions successives de l'exécutif
depuis le 15 juin plusieurs mesures sont
entrées en vigueur
d'abord l'ouverture de la vaccination
aux adolescents mais aussi un délai
raccourci pour recevoir sa deuxième dose
de vaccin passant de 35 à 21 jours au
minimum
vous hésitez à vous faire vacciner en
juin parce que vous serez en vacances en
juillet n'hésitez plus nous modifions
les systèmes de rendez vous pour vous
permettre de programmer votre rappel
entre 21 et 40 9 jours après la première
injection comme une prise de conscience
soudaine mais nécessaire selon plusieurs
études évaluant l'efficacité des
principaux vaccin face à ce variant
delta efficace à 90% contre des formes
graves pour les patients ayant reçu deux
doses
en revanche lorsqu'une seule injection a
eu lieu
l'efficacité retombe à 33% l'adoption
d'une obligation vaccinale c'est une
notion politique ce n'est pas une notion
scientifique moi je suis un
épidémiologiste ce que je préfère c'est
que le tout le monde soit vaccinée
le plus possible il faut en tout cas que
plus de 85 % de la population soit
vaccinée
je ne sais pas si ça doit passer par des
obligations si ça n'est pas le cas
peut-être que dans certains endroits et
où dans certains segments de la
population
ça pourrait être une obligation le
danger est bel et bien présent et
l'allègement des restrictions un double
enjeu pour le gouvernement un retour à
la vie normale
adossé à une politique vaccinale
agressif et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis liverpool avec
francesco rizzotto professeur de droit
européen les universités et jill c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
bonsoir francesco rizzotto merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france on va donc
s'intéresser particulièrement à la
situation au royaume uni avec vous parce
qu'il ya eu plus de dix milles 4 kovy
dans 24 heures une première depuis
février c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
comment expliquer ce saut chiffres il
témoigne de l'échec d'une stratégie
sanitaire outre-manche a amerri doit de
faire avancer leur suggère que le
gouvernement a commis une erreur il ya
cinq ou six semaines
en refusant de fermer les frontières
avec l'inde c'est aussi simple que cela
amsterdam est une erreur une erreur de
jugement et nous en payons maintenant le
prix ces nombreux suggère et un rapport
devrait être publié aujourd'hui virus
dans certaines
du pays n'est plus sous contrôle et
qu'il ya une croissance exponentielle
notamment dans la région du nord-est
c'est l'un des foyers comme on dit donc
nous faisons face à des défis importants
le royaume uni n'est pourtant pas le
seul pays européen à avoir tardé à
fermer ses frontières il y en a qui
n'ont même pas fait aujourd'hui encore
avec avec l'inde vous imputer cette
explosion
cette recrudescence du virus à à ce seul
fait qu'il fait aucun doute que son
était la cause ce variant delta et 60%
plus con terminant que le variant alpha
l'ancien maria britannique sein d'autres
pays n'ont pas fermer leurs frontières
non plus je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
sur glace mais comparons par exemple les
chiffreurs au royaume uni et en italie
en italie le taux d'incidence états unis
300 et le nombre de décès et plus par le
taux de décès encore plus bas mais le
nombre d'infections bien plus élevé il
n'y a pas de solution magique un
problème mais il faut éviter les fuites
malheureusement je crois que c'est très
très stupide et tonus évitables l'accord
du gouvernement
et quand dément avoir su à l'époque que
le brillant ce qui l'est déjà mais c'est
impossible à s'ignorer lors du g7 a mis
à l'honneur les ministres des affaires
étrangères a dû être grise l isolement
donc il n'y a vraiment aucune excuse
pourtant au royaume-uni 80 % au moins
des adultes ont reçu une dose alors pas
la fameuse deuxième dose de vaccin
ça ne suffit pas comment vous expliquer
cette typologie parce que c'est vrai
qu'on apprend que ces clusters ont lieu
dans certains quartiers seulement il ne
concerne pas nécessairement tout le pays
avec leicester c'est au sein des classes
jeunes et puis les moins de 18 ans par
exemple et lorsque je ne sont pas
vaccinés donc on n'a pas besoin d'être
docteur pour comprendre que les
personnes qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
seront les plus vulnérables mais nous
avons fait un pari très audacieux avec
cet unique dose bien tout en étant dans
l'intervalle jusqu'à la deuxième c'est
maintenant nous essayons d'accélérer
leur expulsion pour les premières et les
se compose donc c'est vraiment le course
contre la montre
au cours du mois suivant qui s'annonce
le gouvernement a les crocs mais il ne
levait total des restrictions le 19
juillet aux foules mais est donc nommé
ce truc
le gouvernement est plus optimiste à mon
sens il mieux être très réaliste et
avant les plus jeunes que les groupes
innovation soit vacciné je pense qu'il
faudra rester très prudent avant de
réouvrir le pays c'est ma conviction
intime
l'idée que tout va revenir à la normale
d'ici au 19 juillet c'est simplement du
fantasme
je sens qu'ils l'aient faudra tout vingt
deux semaines un mois de plus avant de
pouvoir ré ouvrir le pays alors le
variant delta semble avant tout se
propager dans les quartiers défavorisés
est ce qu'il ya une responsabilité du
gouvernement pour cela dans le sens où
il n'y a peut-être pas assez de de
pédagogie qui a été fait ou le vaccin
est peut-être difficile dax peu d'accès
à tout d'un manque de place et une fois
que je pense qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs
ont voté la pauvreté bien sûr les
conditions de vie le fait que ces gens
n'ont pas faussé au toujours la
possibilité de maintenir leurs distances
avec les autres que certaines portions
la population ont pensé que cela ne les
toucheraient jamais il ya peut-être
effectivement opté raisons économiques
par exemple les gens ne pouvaient pas
interrompre leur travail
donc il ya sans doute de multiples
raisons expliquant que partie de la
population qui ne seront pas aisées qui
doivent travailler pour survivre
souffriront davantage ou changer la
culture changer le mode de vie ce que
nécessite ce virus vraiment et gageure
je ne t'aime pas le gouvernement en
l'occurrence c'est je pense presque dans
la nature des choses que les gens plus
défavorisés souffriront davantage
malheureusement alors boris johnson
lui a réagi en employant un langage
fleuri envers son ministre de la santé
qu'il a qualifiée pardonnez-moi de la
traduction de de nul voilà
comment sont accueillis ces noms
d'oiseaux au royaume uni c'est quand
même pas banal mais à haïti que boris
diaw
il admet marc johnson et soie ou x2
maculent le plus machiavélique le plus
intelligent des premières ministre
pousse quand tu as he min les plus
chanceux dominique commença à édicter
des règles et les arguments et il
s'agirait peut-être tu n'as plus
revanche contre boris johnson mais
est-ce que cela tu vas kristensen
je ne pense pas sauf peut-être eu parmi
ces gens qui veulent apprécier déjà pas
mais je pense que les règles de la
politique ont changé dans ce pays 2
à deux jours les hommes politiques le
film attire on peut avoir un ministre
décrit comme toutes les filles comme un
cas désespéré mais cela ne veut pas dire
ministre ne va pas disparaître
boris johnson ne veut pas se débarrasser
de matin comme compression très simple
s'il se débarrasse de massacre alors il
n'y aura plus de bouc émissaire pour
prêcher ne sonne il est en quelque sorte
son bouclier face aux erreurs merci
beaucoup francesco rizzotto d'avoir été
avec nous en direct assure rt france et
en russie également la situation
sanitaire se détériore plus
particulièrement à moscou les autorités
ont décidé d'employer les grands moyens
les précisions avec notre correspondante
à moscou on verra goffman vaccination
obligatoire contre le coc vide pour le
secteur des services moscou et sa région
prenne des mesures drastiques afin
d'arrêter la hausse importante des
contaminations près de 14000 cas de
kevin en russie donc
ce que 6001 moscou ont été enregistrés
ces dernières vingt quatre heures le
maire de la capitale sergueï sobianine a
qualifié la situation dans la ville de
dramatique
l'évolution de la situation liée aux
covit 19 reste dramatique plus de douze
mille personnes se trouvent dans les
hôpitaux dans divers états de gravité le
taux d'infection a déjà atteint celui
des périodes de pic de l'année dernière
à cause de la situation épidémiologique
extrêmement grave
le médecin sanitaire en chef pour la
ville de moscou a adopté aujourd'hui une
résolution relative à la vaccination
obligatoire des employés du secteur des
services
environ 20 millions de personnes
habitent dans l'agglomération de moscou
moscou se trouve au carrefour de toutes
les routes
ce sont nous qui faisons face aux coups
les plus durs de la pandémie c'est pour
cette raison que nous avons en premier
lieu besoin d'une protection sérieuse
contre cette maladie dangereuse et pour
empêcher la mort de milliers de
moscovites helena andré 20 médecins
sanitaire en chef de la ville de moscou
a à son tour chargé les chefs
d'entreprise de faire vacciner son % des
employés d'ici le 15 juillet pour la
première injection
d'ici le 15 août pour la deuxième la
situation épidémiologique liées à
l'infection coronavirus dans la ville de
moscou est considérée comme mauvaise
depuis le 6 juin 2021
le taux de nouveaux cas enregistrés
augmente de manière plus intense
l'augmentation journalière est temps de
11% à cette date et allant jusqu'à 20%
les jours suivants la situation liée à
l'infection au cours aux navires us à
moscou se détériore lors de l'analyse de
l'incidence il a été constaté que les
individus en âge de travailler
les 18 à 60 ans soit 60 % de la
population étaient plus susceptibles
d'attraper la maladie et il ya quelques
jours le maire de moscou avaient signé
un décret prévoyant il semaines chômées
du 12 au 20 juin une décision ayant pour
but d'arrêter la hausse du nombre de cas
et de préserver la vie des gens sergueï
sobianine a également pris la décision
de fermer les airs du jeu pour les
enfants dans les parcs et dans les
centres commerciaux jusqu'au 20 juin et
a appelé les employeurs à privilégier le
télétravail pour ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés contre le co lead
c'est après dix ans d'absence laurent
gbagbo est rentré aujourd'hui en côte
d'ivoire ce retour de l'ancien président
au nom de la réconciliation nationale
n'a pas forcément eu l'alluré ce comté
et nicholas pettit ce sont ses premiers
pas en côte d'ivoire depuis dix ans
laurent gbagbo vient d'atterrir à
l'aéroport d'abidjan pour accueillir
l'ancien président et des dirigeants de
son parti le front populaire ivoirien
des proches et plusieurs dizaines de
notamment le front populaire ivoirien
souhaité que le retour au pays de
laurent gbagbo soient populaires mais il
n'en est rien déjà privé d'adieu à ses
soutiens lors de son décollage à
bruxelles l'homme fort du pays de 2000 à
2010 est encore tenu à l'écart de ses
partisans sur le sol ivoirien
la police fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser la foule avant même son
arrivée
une situation dénoncée par le parti de
l'ancien président nous sommes étonnés
au moment où les gens s'apprêtent à lui
le prix dans leurs labos qui soit gaz et
même avec des pommes lacrymogènes
tout alla au carrefour akwaba donc la
cale fou de koumassi il ya eu les plaies
des jeunes personnes qui sont venues qui
ont été gazés on apprend que répond
d'aquabike 40 interpellé déjà on ne
comprend pas cours pourtant placé sous
le signe de la réconciliation nationale
par alassane ouattara qui n'a d'ailleurs
pas fait le déplacement
retour n'a pas vraiment des allures de
fête malgré ses dix années passées loin
de la côte d'ivoire dont une bonne
partie en prison laurent gbagbo a
conservé une forte aura auprès d'une
partie de la population ivoirienne en
particulier les jeunes
certains d'entre eux se font déjà une
idée bien précise de la suite des
événements il est nette dans la
politique il n'est pas un banal et ça
maintenant
le temps n'est pas en quoi il est
beaucoup plus cela m'a donné il va les
voir continuer pour le déclare nous à le
voir au prochain mandat avec laurent
gbagbo dans ses rangs l'opposition est
également porté par le parti
démocratique de côte d'ivoire de
l'ancien président henri konan-bédié
pourrait prendre de l'épaisseur
définitivement acquitté de crimes contre
l'humanité est de retour dans son pays
l'horizon politique semble désormais
dégagée pour laurent gbagbo
un horizon aux allures de promesses en
train de s'exprimer je suis heureux de
retrouver la côte d'ivoire et l'afrique
vient il de dire
nous sommes avec louis que mes yeux
président du club de l'information
africaine pour commenter dans ce retour
louis keumayou bonsoir après toutes ces
années
comment ce retour au pays est il perçu à
abidjan je pense que le président gbagbo
est parti dans un déshonneur qui était
hôtel à la fois pour lui pour sa femme
pour son enfant pour sa famille
politique
et aujourd'hui il revient avec des
honneurs qui lui sont refusés
même s'il rentre en tant qu' en tant
qu'ancien chef d'état et qu'il est
accueillie comme telle
yam néanmoins il a néanmoins cette
volonté de le maintenir dans la position
d'un leader politique d'un camp plutôt
que deux hommes d'état qui pourrait
fédérer l'ensemble des ivoiriens et
prendre sa part active dans le processus
de réconciliation du pays
clermont laurent gbagbo pour vous
aujourd'hui il a un avenir politique en
côte d'ivoire laurent gbagbo a déjà nés
tâche politique est celui de d'avoir eu
le courage de lutter pour le
multipartisme à un moment où le premier
président de la côte d'ivoire houphouët
boigny pour ne pas le citer était encore
dans sa toute puissance et que personne
ne contestait son autorité c'est lui qui
a donné les premiers coups de boutoir
pour obtenir la libéralisation de la vie
politique en côte d'ivoire
c'est un animal politique il n'a jamais
oublié qu'il était un homme politique il
est féru d'histoire et je ne sais pas
s'il maintiendra sa volonté d'agir en
tant qu'acteur partie prenante de la vie
politique ou de devenir le sèche qui
pourrait aujourd'hui à la manière d'un
henson mandela fédérer d'abord sa
famille politique
ensuite les ivoiriens entre eux pour
qu'ils fassent nation ça c'est la chose
qui est la plus difficile à prévoir mais
une chose est certaine c'est que gbagbo
en revenant en côte d'ivoire ne tire pas
un trait sur son histoire politique
en tout cas le président ouattara avril
dernier a donné son feu vert à ce retour
de laurent gbagbo ça laisse quand même
présager l'heure de la réconciliation
pour les ivoiriens
le dernier gouvernement de alassane
ouattara a pris en compte cette
nécessité de réconcilier les ivoiriens
le peuple ivoirien non pas seulement les
leaders n'ont pas seulement les camps
politiques
mais toute la famille qui constitue la
nation ivoirienne
c'est un premier très bon pas la
deuxième chose c'est que les acteurs
étaient encore pour la plupart à
l'extérieur est l'un des acteurs majeurs
c'est le président laurent gbagbo il est
rentré je pense qu'en faisant cette
conjoncture d'évènements favorables avec
le ministère de la réconciliation et le
retour de laurent gbagbo il devrait y
avoir un début de réconciliation
nationale comme il n'y en a pas vu
pendant les dix dernières années et donc
si avec ouattara gbagbo
conan bédié et guillaume soro pour ne
citer que ces acteurs là on est arrivé à
poser les bases d'une réconciliation qui
fasse que la côte d'ivoire à l'instar du
rwanda qui a connu le génocide des tutsi
à l'instar de l'afrique du sud qui a
connu
apartheid arrive aussi à surmonter ses
démons
ce sera un très grand pas et j'espère
que ce retour est elle si que c'est une
volonté politique exprimée vont aboutir
à une véritable réconciliation entre les
ivoiriens
en tout cas laurent gbagbo aura passé
huit ans en détention préventive faut
finalement être acquitté de crimes
contre l'humanité par la cour pénale
internationale est ce que certains dans
le pays le voit encore comme un
comptable malgré tout oui les
associations de victimes de la crise
post électorale de la présidentielle de
2010 kia qui a duré jusqu'en 2011
il y en a encore qui continue
aujourd'hui d'estimer que le camp de
laurent gbagbo et laurent gbagbo
lui-même n'ont pas assez payé de tous
les crimes qu'ils ont commis
mais une chose est certaine c'est que
quand on fait le bilan de cette crise là
c'est déjà la coagulation de nombreuses
crises qui sont nées de la mort du
premier président de la côte d'ivoire
coffret de bois ni et du fait que sa
succession n'avait pas été très bien
préparé et que dans le concept
d'ivoirité qui avait été utile des époux
des cartes et alassane ouattara de la
succession a engendré d'autres crises et
que 2010 n'était que l'explosion en
réalité d'une série de crise qui couvait
déjà depuis de 1993 est donc aujourd'hui
il est important que l'on se rend compte
que beaucoup de gens sont victimes
mais la plus grande victime ici c'est la
nation ivoirienne parce que elle est
très divisée aujourd'hui il ya peu de
chances que en restant sur le logiciel
actuel les ivoiriens se réconcilient
donc je pense pour ma part qu'il serait
utile pour la réconciliation que l'on ne
soit pas en train de retirer de nouveaux
dossiers a ajouté et hull et crimes
contre l'humanité qui ont été proférées
les accusations de crimes contre
l'humanité qui ont été proférées contre
laurent gbagbo
il est allé à la cour pénale
internationale il a été blanchi
aujourd'hui on sort de nouveaux crimes
avec le cas
de la bcao n'y a pas eu un seul cas ce
que je nomme casse dans le nord de la
côte d'ivoire qui avaient servi à
financer la rébellion
si on doit ouvrir les dossiers il faut
les ouvrir tous mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la priorité est à la
réconciliation et que c'est l'enjeu le
chantier le plus important
laurent gbagbo n'est ce pas aussi le
symbole de la résistance 1 face aux
ingérences française on se souvient que
nicolas sarkozy avait avait tout fait
pour l'écarter du pouvoir
il ne s'est pas contenté de il a dit il
a reconnu ce n'est même pas une
interprétation voulons faire dans l'un
des livres qui là qu'il est rédigé il
avait dit qu'il a tout fait pour écarter
des cartes et laurent gbagbo de la
présidence d installer alassane dramane
ouattara
les choses sont claires c'est à dire
qu'au delà de toute la bataille qui a eu
sur le résultat des élections de
l'élection présidentielle de 2010
il y avait une volonté préméditée des
cartes et laurent gbagbo est donc une
ingérence visible et réelle de la france
de nicolas sarkozy
en l'occurrence qui était le présent
français à l'époque d'écarter le
candidat en faveur d'un autre je pense
que toute l'histoire qui a lu après avec
le procès avec le avec le croisement des
deux alassane dramane ouattara
tout cela montre aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui le concept même des
ingérences d'humanité ou d'ingérence
doit être revu complètement parce que
quand on est un peuple souverain on doit
gérer sa souveraineté soi même le linge
sale se lave en famille c'est ce qui n'a
pas eu lieu en côte d'ivoire c'est ce
qui est en train de se produire au mali
également où la force aujourd'hui estime
que si les maliens doivent dialoguer
entre eux il ya des bons mâles aident
des mauvais maliens que on peut
dialoguer avec les bons mais pas avec
les mauves est le résultat de la crise
post électorale de 2010 en côte d'ivoire
nous montre que ce choix a été néfaste
est dramatique pour la démocratie pour
le peuple et ne vais pas être répétée au
maine
merci beaucoup louis keumayou président
du club de l'information africaine
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin de
cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
nadège abderrazak
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans les
relations entre la russie et jour d'hui
venir à